well six former members of biden's
transition covet advisory team are now
suggesting
that um
many say
we should have followed all along this
advice
live with covid
those doctors wrote in the journal of
american medical association
the goal for the new normal with covet
19 does not include eradication or
elimination it should be recognizing
that covid is but one of several
circulating respiratory viruses
dr marty mccary
fox news contributor and professor at
johns hopkins university school of
medicine is in focus now dr always great
to have you on the program uh so
shutting down the virus you told us
months ago maybe even years ago
you can't do that like you just can't do
it with anything else but you can work
to contain it
well that's right and it's been very
hard to get through to president biden
you know he's got medical advisors but
they're like-minded and they're quite
frankly
out of step i think with the rest of the
medical community many of us have tried
to get other points of view into the
white house and here you are seeing a
group of democrat political appointees
that is those who are considered loyal
to the democrat medical establishment
like dr zeke emanuel basically defect
now and go around the guidance go around
the channels through dr fauci
and write in our top medical journals
that we need an entirely new approach
one that's based on common sense it's
interesting as you were talking i wrote
down the word sycophants
because not only do they all agree with
each other these advisors uh there there
are some politics at play too and and
who doesn't want to be in the
president's popular circle i suppose
they should look at his poll numbers uh
the awful saga continues in chicago
illinois dr mccary classes there have
been canceled for a third day as the
teachers union there continues to defy
city officials
pushing to get children back in school
so the mayor wants this now
and that fight is heating up in other
school districts now leaving more
parents in the lurch in oakland
california for example a group of
teachers reportedly planned a sick out
for today some of them telling local
affiliates that they won't march
themselves into a death trap
in san francisco unions in the school
district failed to reach an agreement on
a testing plan that teachers have been
demanding the president of the united
educators of san francisco says they
want kids in school but nothing is off
the table take a look
this is a school district that's
basically been shrugging shoulders and
acting like covet testing and prevention
isn't important if safe working
conditions are not met then it's very
possible people are working in
conditions that are unsafe and that is
not okay
dr mccary a death trap in classrooms for
children and you say what to that
well look that rhetoric is very damaging
because what it does is it looks only at
viral replication and it does not
consider mental health and people are
dying from mental health problems and
that's something that where if you want
to construct an argument that the
environment is unsafe you can always do
it looking very vocally at only one
organ system if you look at the totality
of harm it is clearly there
developmental suicide we've seen mental
health worsen
among 31 percent of kids according to a
study a mental health crisis
so you can always construct
a medical argument around the eternal
excuse of an environment being unsafe
but if that's the case
then the kids should not be in
automobiles which account for more
deaths than covet 19 over the last two
years look these teachers unions say
that they're looking at the science
if you could communicate directly to
them what would you tell them about that
look we are imposing harsh policies on a
defenseless population ask them ask the
children ask them what their risk
tolerance is because there has never
been a documented case of a healthy
child in the united states dying of
covet and for kids with the comorbidity
their risk is equal to influenza and
they can get vaccin they can get
vaccinated or take other precautions
so
if we're going to do this now we're
going to have to do it forever because
influenza is not going away and 10 to 25
percent of kids will develop a
respiratory infection every year with
similar outcomes look just a year ago
last summer when we started to open up
and people were getting on planes they
were telling grandparents look when
you're around your little one's rsv is
very real we had hat on mask and then we
were taking them off in the warmer
months and little ones can get that
particularly troublesome and deadly
respiratory
uh disease just your quick thought on
that yeah
well you know what we're seeing with
covet is such a stigmatized virus at the
exclusion of all other respiratory
pathogens we saw it with hiv remember
when parents said i'm not going to let
my kid go to school where there's a
child with hiv even though the science
didn't support any human human
transmission in a classroom we're seeing
that highly stigmatized politicalization
right now with kovid wow i want to get
to this modernist ceo says people may
need another booster
and that would be like four shots total
by this fall and maybe beyond he says
waiting for the data in the coming weeks
on how long boosters last uh is what we
should do and says he does not expect
the news to be great
dr mccary you're firing back at the fda
for posting a video that argues even
people who've been vaccinated and got
coveted giving them natural immunity
still should get these boosters you
suggested that that is misinformation
here's what you tweeted
this is so disappointing to see it's
extremely misleading many government
doctors have lost their scientific
objectivity and sadly ignore the
overwhelming data of natural immunity dr
mccary your argument
well look natural immunity has now been
studied in over a hundred studies and
there all the more research in the world
is not going to convince public health
officials who are politically appointed
and loyal
scientists who are have lost their
objectivity
look at how the fda bypassed their
expert panel just to get boosters
approved for young people this is no
longer a scientific authority
organization natural immunity is real
and when we talk about mandates as the
court is considering
you know they don't do mandates very
well they ignored natural immunity the
dosing between intervals was not optimal
and the boosters and young kid kids is
not supported with any data same with
some of the other mandates real quickly
if you have had coverage you've been
vaccinated can you still get a booster
if you're in one of those high-risk
categories or do you have to wait a
period of time
there's no need for a booster your
natural immunity and vaccine immunity is
hybrid immunity that's the best immunity
you can get
many people around the world need to get
vaccinated those doses should be going
to them all right dr mccary let's do
some breaking news now we've been
keeping our eye on that dr wolinski solo
rare for her she's usually in the big
task force group
talk today and update by phone a lot of
questions about the revised cdc
guidelines telling people who test
positive for covid to isolate for five
days now instead of the previous ten
uh and and so she's getting hit with
this and just now dr wolinski
said this
if on day five
you don't have symptoms anymore then we
can talk about um you know coming out of
isolation with a mask on strictly
massing for those remaining five days
first of all your initial reaction
well i think the bigger problem is not
that
what the cdc is saying it's the fact
that we have this intense dependency on
the cdc to adjudicate on every aspect of
american life the cdc also says that
people should not eat meat medium rare
they've said that for a long time we've
got to get away from this intense
dependency and recognize that we they're
they're not going to land the plane with
a soft landing they could take off and
put a lot of restrictions in place but
they don't have good off-ramp criteria
we got to turn to common sense
uh real quickly
so when she says well we'll talk about
it who who does she envision we're
talking to when we reach that five-day
point we have to figure out if it's time
to test go back to work or back to
school who does she think we're talking
to she didn't say doctors the pollsters
look i think they're talking to
pollsters probably they're trying to
sense public sentiment and that's why
they leak
recommendations to the media before they
announce them dr mccary in focus today
thank you very much for your time and
expertise thanks